i got this real [ __ ] thing i do it's
called thinking
and i'm not a very good american because
i like to form my own opinions
i don't just roll over when i'm told to
sad to say most americans just roll over
on command
not me i have certain rules i live by
my first rule i don't believe anything
the government tells me
nothing zero
i mean you're born absolutely free
except for laws of nature those
if you drink you get drunk that's a law
if you
if you get old you die that's a law too
if you sit on attack you will bleed from
the ass these are the only
laws that you're born with and any
government just [ __ ] you out of that
type of freedom if you
if you really think you're free tonight
you hero
officer bob you're a free man you live
in a free country but you're just
you go upstairs you take your own beer
you
risked your life for you sit on the hood
of your monster truck in the parking lot
drink your beer and see how long it is
before
actual veteran cops come by and pound on
you with truncheons on the kidneys to
show
why can't i do it i'm just having a beer
i don't know
it's the lotto you don't [ __ ] around you
can't drive down the street without a
seat belt on why not i don't know you're
gonna
put on a helmet you can't sit in your
own backyard naked your own
filthy dirty flesh that you're born with
you know that body you carry around
filthy you can't sit up why not i don't
know that's just the way it is
you're mother free you're not free in
the least you need a diploma in this
country to cut hair
you're free you need to keep your tray
in the upright and lock position during
takeoff
it's not just a hack premise it's a
[ __ ] felony
and [ __ ] the hero sky con pool i could
throw you off the plane as a terrorist
we're going why do i have to have this
this doesn't make sense
they say if you give a man a fish
he'll eat for a day but if you teach a
man to fish
then he's going to get a fishing license
but he doesn't have any money
so he's going to get a job and he has to
get into the social security system and
pay
taxes and now you're gonna audit the
poor [ __ ] sucker
because he's not really good with math
you pull the irs van up to your house
he'll take all your [ __ ] he'll take your
black velvet elvis and your batman
toothbrush and your penis pump
and that all goes up for auction with
the burden of proof on you
because you forgot to carry the one
because you were just worried about
eating a [ __ ] fish and you couldn't
even
cook the fish because you needed a
permit for an open flame
and then the health department is going
to start asking you a lot of questions
about where are you going to dump the
scales and the guts
this is not a sanitary environment and
ladies and gentlemen if you get it
if you get sick of it all at the end of
the day
not even legal to kill yourself in this
country
thanks again john ashcroft you weird
bible addict can't even handle his own
drug
you were born free you got [ __ ] out of
half of it and you wave a flag
celebrating
this whole country has a manhood problem
big manhood problem in the usa you can
tell from the language we use
language always gives you away what did
we do wrong in vietnam
we pulled out
ah not a very manly thing to do is it
when you're [ __ ] people you gotta
stay in there and [ __ ] them good
[ __ ] all the way [ __ ] till the end
[ __ ] them to death
[ __ ] them to death [ __ ] them to death
stay in there and keep [ __ ] them
until they're all dead
we left a few women and children alive
in vietnam and we haven't felt good
about ourselves since that's why in the
persian gulf george bush had to say this
will not be another vietnam
he actually used these words he said
this time we're going
all the way imagine an american
president using the sexual slang of a 13
year old to describe his foreign policy
if you want to know what happened in the
persian gulf just remember the names of
the two men
who were running that war dick cheney
and colin powell
somebody got [ __ ] in the ass
and i was talking about some stuff
earlier but the other side of it is
how sad how sad is it that we we can't
trust our government
i'm not saying that this is a faker hoax
but
there's a there's at least a chance that
this is fake
like it doesn't sound crazy anymore to
say that
i grew up trusting like i grew up
trusting the president the
the the police the fact like we there's
at least a inkling that we can't trust
what they're telling us
well america is at a crossroads right
now
you know americans were at a crossroads
with the police
america's crossroads with african
americans
americans in the crossroads of latinos
want a crossroads right now and this
crossroad
could lead to a civil war
you know uh seems like there's a lot of
uh
african-american hate crime now
on other people the videos have been
posted you know
people feel unsafe uncertain
you know when why it's going to be scary
is because why i got scary as a human
being
when my heart turned black that's when i
used to steal
when my mother died i thought the world
turned on me and
the government turned on me they wanted
paperwork
for me to get money that was supposed to
come to me from my father and my mother
so all those things broke down so i'm
reliving it
i'm seeing people go through what i went
through at 16
losing their job losing your mother
losing
a wife losing a child losing your job
that you've been doing for 20 years
people cameramen directors ads you know
all those people
people who went to school for editing
and been out here editing for 20 years
they're not shooting nothing
right now right now they're sitting at
home tidbly winking
you know yeah what about the kids on the
other hand who just graduated college
what about those kids and those dudes
what about not having a graduation you
know
all these things are wearing on people
yeah so yes
your non-trust in the government your
confusion and the morning of the death
of you not having a job
you know two weeks you lose your
benefits i mean i hate to be [ __ ]
joey downer
but yes this weighs on people the reason
why we do the podcast
is so you understand that you're not the
only one
i'm telling you guys you're not the only
one so please
uh listen
like i said it once i live by these
things you never see a bookie but a
part-time job
and there's no dentist prison
but anyway and they said you know they
had to break down the compound
because child abuse was stepping up
well that's true how come we don't see
bradley tanks knocking down catholic
churches
you know i mean if in fact child abuse
is your concern actually folks i don't
know if you all seen this there's a tape
kind of bootleg going around
of showing film of the bradley tanks not
knocking as the official story was small
holes to insert tear gas
but crashing the building off of its
[ __ ] foundation and
fire shooting out of the tanks the fbi
and the atf are liars and murderers
and janet reno and president clinton
either a knowingly passed on a lie
or b are so out of touch with their own
[ __ ] arms of their government that
they're incompetent and clinton should
be impeached
immediately case [ __ ] close and you
all have probably seen the footage
but it's sort of different than the
official story isn't it small holes tear
gas
giant holes flamethrowers they burn
these people
in their homes okay that's our
government
okay i've seen the tape and
it's [ __ ] real and um whatever make
your own conclusions you haven't seen it
so
it's you know whatever but old clint you
know there's i have no illusions about
these [ __ ] i know there's 12 guys
who run the [ __ ] world and uh
they own every company and you know it's
it's it's
fact you can look it up i'm not a
conspiracy nut this is all on paper
there really are 22 families who run and
own 50
of the mainstream media which is where
we get our news
and uh and it's true it's a fact you can
look it up i don't
you know i i i can't be this big of an
[ __ ] without having the truth to back
me up
otherwise i'd be a [ __ ] nut doing
this
but see if you have the truth with you
you can do this
you know if i had to say to you what is
the answer i would say massive bloodshed
i really would i don't really honestly
deep down believe in political action i
think the system
contracts and expands as it wants to it
accommodates these changes
i think the civil rights movement was an
accommodation on the part of the those
who own the country
i think they see where their
self-interest lies they see a certain
amount of freedom
seems good an illusion of liberty give
these people
give these people a voting day every
year so that they'll have the illusion
of meaningless choice
meaningless choice that we go like
slaves and say joy i voted
the the limits of debate in this country
are are are
are established before the debate even
begins and everyone else is marginalized
they're made to seem either to be
communist
or with some sort of disloyal person a
kook there's a word
and now it's conspiracy see they've made
that something that that is that is
should not be even entertained for a
minute that powerful people
might get together and have a plan
doesn't happen you're a
kook you're a conspiracy buff so
who the only way you cure that death
bloodshed
i don't advocate it but i see that it's
really the only